make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and you
know with everything going on with
wandavision and the fact that i'm going
to be out of town again this weekend
um i thought it'd be fun to kind of do a
follow-up to the house of m event not
really a follow-up per se one of the
things that that happened with the
original house of m event
is that we didn't really know how some
things happened right for example you
pick up with the main house of him story
and like magneto rules the world but you
never really found out how it was that
happened
right it was simply just assumed that
was part of what the scarlet witch did
right that wanda maximoff had basically
altered reality to give everybody their
greatest desires and you just kind of
picked up with things just being that
way uh the reality is that
after the events of house of m so going
into like 2009 2010
uh marvel released a series of stories
that tied into the main event itself
that was designed to basically tell the
backstory how things got to that point
and so in this particular comic
which is called house of m's civil war
we're basically covering how it is
that the scarlet witch had altered
reality in such a way
to where it led to magneto effectively
taking over the world
how it is the house of magnus came into
existence and so there's a few things to
understand here right the origin of
magneto
largely appears to be the same there's
not really a whole lot of difference
here between
the origin of magneto as it existed in
the main marvel universe and the origin
of magneto as it exists in the way that
wanda maxed them off had altered reality
right you still had
a lot of the key points that basically
happened in the same way that um
that the family of of magneto was
basically tossed into concentration
camps magneto was the only survivor
ah this led to him eventually meeting
magda albeit under a few different
circumstances the two of them fell in
love they had a daughter
the people in his hometown realized he
was a mutant they kind of freaked out
they attacked him
set his home on fire his daughter anya
died and then magneto freaked out
you know unleashed his powers for the
first time and basically killed
everybody leading to his wife magda
fleeing while she was pregnant with
quicksilver and the scarlet witch right
so
a lot of those things are still intact
the big difference here
comes in the form that unlike what we've
seen in the main marvel universe where
magneto kind of went forward and did a
few things here and there that what he
does here
is this is when he kind of launches his
full-on crusade against mutant
oppression right in the in the aftermath
of anya dying he just basically ends up
traveling around the world going through
going to france a few other places
and starts liberating mutants everywhere
he can find them now he did do that
to a degree in the maine marvel universe
but not on the same level that we're
seeing now
this and the fact that he ends up coming
across a woman named susan dane who he
ends up getting pregnant and then of
course tells her get away get as far
away from me as you can
because the life i lead is exceedingly
dangerous and it can get you killed we
of course know
is the mother of lorna dane also known
as pilars
but the whole idea behind this is that
while all that's going on you've got
bolivar trask basically working
on the creation of the sentinel program
now this is one of the big differences
here and we're not really given a lot of
the a lot of
insight here in the maine marvel
universe you had a program called
called project wide awake and project
wide awake was basically
the federal government alongside like
every single
national security organization that
existed in the us at the time right so
the cia the fbi
uh state sheriff's office unidentified
intelligence agencies
all the way down to local cops right it
was just this great big huge campaign
to contain and control the mutant threat
because they largely didn't know what to
do with the mutant population right now
project wide awake ended up sort of
phasing out as time went on
and that eventually became weapon x or
weapons plus as you guys know it weapons
plus was kind of was kind of the
overarching thing
project wide awake was one facet of it
but by the time project wide awake had
gone away
weapons plus had graduated into like
weapons five and six and seven
all the way up to weapon x which was the
creation of wolverine right but here
in the house of m reality none of that
really seems to have taken place
we do have the the kind of project wide
awake concept insofar as
bolivar trask has basically created
sentinels for the purpose of
finding and capturing mutants but that's
basically it the big thing about all
this
is that while all this is happening
these mutants are traveling around in
different locations we end up picking up
in egypt
right and egypt is a scenario where
magneto basically witnesses a couple of
individuals being killed by a sentinel
until he's able to intervene and stop
the signal itself
but while all that's going on we end up
finding out that magneto
is being watched by apocalypse right one
of the very first mutants to ever exist
an apocalypse abides by the philosophy
of social darwinism
only the strong deserve to survive and
the weak will perish to make way for the
strong and so what this does is
it leads to magneto almost being
combative towards apocalypse over the
fact that apocalypse watched all this
happen
and his response is i let it i just sat
there and watched because i wanted to
see which among you were the strongest
to fight off this sentinel threat that
could potentially lead
you know lead mutant kind into a greater
future and so it's by virtue of
apocalypse's tutelage to a degree
that magneto begins to rise and become
this guy who starts to lead the human
race
this and the various escapades that he
gets into right because we do a lot of
time
jumping here we pick up a few months
later and we end up finding out that
alongside apocalypse magneto has amassed
a pretty sizable uh mutant army to his
to his cause right it's not by any
standards like omits it's not colossal
numbering in like the millions right but
it's a pretty sizable number right a few
hundred certainly uh and and with their
help he's basically traveled from one
place to another
liberating various mutants that he finds
and so what you end up having here is a
situation where after they're able to
liberate some of these uh some of these
encampments
in uh in egypt it leads to a kind of
confrontation between apocalypse and
magneto and the reason why
is because in apocalypses in his mindset
the more like any human they leave alive
is a human that would ultimately try to
kill them and so the only real policy
that they can they can essentially adopt
here is to kill
every human they can find right to
basically just eliminate every single
human
that they come across the problem with
this is that much like we've seen in the
main marvel universe here in house of m
magneto's philosophy is very similar in
the sense that he sees
and knows what happens when you have
this sort of zero tolerance policy
adopted by a particular group
that's effectively waging war right
because what you have right now is in
essence
humanity fighting against mutant kind
right the war between humans and mutants
that took place in the house of m events
and magneto stands after coming out of
world war ii and all the stuff that he
saw going on in germany is we cannot do
that because if we do we become as bad
as them what this does is it leads to
apocalypse and even a couple other
people
questioning magneto's abilities right
are you really the kind of leader that
we need
if you're not willing to do whatever you
need to do in order to win this conflict
and it's kind of a funny thing here
because this sort of pushes magneto over
the edge to a degree partly when he goes
to fight apocalypse and with apocalypse
being this
you know essentially a demigod kind of
character in the sense that he can shape
shift he can grow to any size he can
manipulate and control the atomic
structure of his body he's got telepathy
telekinesis he can give himself any
superhuman power
outside of reality warping because he
can do so much you almost kind of look
at magneto and see him as a guy that
would stand no real chance to defeat
apocalypse and it's one of the things
that apocalypse even says right there's
no metal here there's no there's nothing
for you to throw at me there's nothing
for you to encase me in
it's not like you can lock me in metal
and suffocate me or anything like that
i am effectively immortal i will never
die of age or illness or anything along
those lines the caveat to this
is he's not really an external he kind
of is to a degree but he can still be
incapacitated and that's exactly what
magneto does he effectively
realizes that in apocalypse's mind his
mind works just like anybody else's then
he's got electrons right he's got
electrical
stuff going through his brain right you
know electrical signals that are going
from his brain to his body and so on and
so forth
just like any other human being right
these electrical impulses
because they're part of the
electromagnetic spectrum can be
manipulated by magneto he quite
literally
creates an emp in the mind of apocalypse
and while it's not enough to kill him
it is certainly enough to weaken him but
everybody here looking around is kind of
like you know he kind of realizes all
right
i need to show a force beyond this not
necessarily one to say i'll kill anybody
who questions me or incapacitate them
but one to say
i'm looking out for you guys as well and
so it becomes something that's very
fortuitous when you end up having all
these sentinels that basically come
flying towards this mutant camp where
magneto resides of course
because they're made of metal he uses
his powers and rips them all to pieces
right just tears them all to pieces and
ends up bringing down
some of these uh reporters from the bbc
who are just kind of like
we're non-combatants man we're just here
to record everything which really asks
the question
if they're there to record a slaughter
how innocent could they possibly be
but magneto ends up letting them live
and then said like basically broadcast
out to the world
and says understand this is the strike
you let on us right you guys attacked us
you guys started seeking us out you used
your sentinels to enslave us to kill us
everywhere you could find them so
understand this humanity started this
war
but we will end it right you declared
war on mutant kind
today mutant kind declares war on you
the crazy
thing is that while all that's happening
one of the people who's watching this
is charles xavier now there are a couple
people who are watching it as well
you've got quicksilver and the scarlet
witch wand to max them off who's going
to become
incredibly important as the story goes
on and then you've got lorna dane right
as a little girl who's watching this
unfold and so you end up picking up in a
place called marysville which is
considered a mutant relocation center
in california right basically a
concentration camp and much like what
you've seen in marvel comics over the
years in the main marvel universe here
in house of m uh marysville is basically
like jenosha right where it's just a
giant prison place it's
just where they hold mutants and then
they just make them work they use their
powers for their own ends or just have
them perform some kind of grunt work or
something like that and where you've got
the blob
right you got this guy who is
essentially indestructible so long as he
his his powers are intact you've got
unis the untouchable who can create an
impenetrable force field around himself
while you do have these mutant collars
around them that are designed to
neutralize their powers
quicksilver races through and basically
deactivates the collars and then in turn
takes the
takes the guns away from the soldiers
and at this point all hell breaks loose
right like you immediately have blob who
just starts tearing all these guys apart
you've got uh you got magneto and you
have polaris who's now grown up so
obviously more than a few years have
passed
and in turn like she's just kind of
brought in and they just start laying
waste to all these sentinels but unlike
what you would expect you or at least
what you would expect here magneto
starts liberating them all and that's
really what happens
from one situation to the next that you
end up having these scenarios where
magneto travels from place to place
liberates all these mutants and they
rally to his side now not every mutant
does right some of them are just like i
want to have anything to do with this
i just want to go live a peaceful life
and they just take off running right but
a good portion of them all rally to him
the funny thing is that you have this
moment where you have a soldier out on a
ridge with a sniper rifle
watching magneto with the intention of
taking him out when suddenly this guy
stops and that's when charles xavier
pops up and says
we need to have a conversation and so
that's one of the things where you start
to realize that one
asteroid m does exist in the house of m
continuity right where you basically
have magneto who's created a kind of
space station for himself that's
composed of
partly asteroid and then part technology
that's effectively their base of
operations
you do have the scarlet witch here but
one of the things that's kind of
consistent in this story as it was in
the main in the the main house of m
story is scarlet witch does not let on
that she's changed everything
as far as all this goes people believe
this has always been their life right
they always believe things have always
been this way
and she makes no comment over the sense
that they're not supposed to be right
that she's altered reality that she's
twisted things up change things inside
out she makes no comment about that and
it's a smart move on her part right for
no one to know that that's the case but
it's also there's also a moment here
where she kind of shifts things up even
if only for a split second right and
it's absolutely cool but you have this
discussion between charles xavier and
magneto which hauls xavier does disagree
with a lot of what magneto's doing here
but magneto's stance is
you don't fully understand the picture
of what's happening right you don't
fully grasp
what's taking place here and so what you
end up getting is him basically bringing
in
a girl by the name of sophia who was
recently released or
really uh rescued from one of these
concentration camps and then he has
xavier read the mind of this girl and
xavier realizes that all kinds of
heinous things were going on here right
physical abuses they were experimenting
on people in the most heinous of ways
just outright massacres all kinds of
stuff right just just
terrible horrible things and the fact
that this is happening at different
locations
all around the world almost leaves
charles xavier and he really kind of
adopts
this somewhat naive mentality when he's
like dude if the world knew what was
going on and the response of magneto is
but they do this is like these what
you've seen here with sophia
that's what's going on in the island of
genocia that's what's going on there
that's what's taking place there and
like the soviet union
gives arms an armament to genocide the
united states contributes to it
everybody
gives jenosha the supplies they need and
they all know what's happening here it's
not as though they're totally unaware
it's not as little the president has no
clue what's going on
every major government in the world is
totally aware of what's happening there
so we can't go to any of these
governments out there and ask them for
aid
if jenosha is going to be liberated then
we're going to liberate it on our own
and so this basically leads to them
traveling to hammer bay in genocia
only to be met by the arrival of what is
in effect the soviet super soldiers
right now this
is by all standards of measurement the
winter guard uh for those of you guys
who are new the winter guard is what
you're going to see in the black widow
film right so if they make reference to
like a quote unquote
superhero team that existed during world
war ii or at least at some point during
the cold war then they're effectively
referencing the winter guard of russia
right which is their answer to the
avengers team but where you have like
all these mutants who come pouring in
with the intention of liberating genosha
of course the winter guard responds to
the forces of magneto and faces off
against them
and all that kind of good stuff but
while that's happening that's designed
to effectively be
a ruse that the real conflict of the
real goal of this is for quicksilver and
charles xavier and
and polaris to travel to these little
prison cells right to go from building
to building in these various prison
cells and liberate as many mutants as
they possibly can
with charles xavier basically clearly
you know clearing their mind
of all the torment and all the suffering
they've gone through allowing them to
regain their faculties
reactivate their powers and then jump
out into the conflict right so it's fast
tracking what is in effect
uh therapy from from ptsd and so of
course you end up having crimson dynamo
who realizes what's going on
and for the most part any any combat he
could offer isn't really all that great
right he actually ends up destroying the
building and bringing it down around
them quick silver man just to get out
with lorna dane uh you know professor
xavier is still
effectively trapped inside but the the
folks on genocide the the soldiers of
genocide
refuse to give up and one of the things
that they're using here are weapons that
are made of like
ceramics or hard plastics things that
magneto cannot easily manipulate
and while he can do things like control
the buildings around him and all that
kind of stuff
at the end of the day he decides not to
instead what he does is he says like i
studied your country i know what your
main export is and your main export
is iron ore so he literally lifts this
entire section of the
of the island right this huge section of
the island the size of a volcano lifts
it up
over top of the main city of genocia and
says
i'm giving you an offer human right i'm
giving you an offer for you
you're your guy who runs the show all
that kind of stuff the offer is this
either you can surrender or i will drop
this whole place on your head and i will
kill every mutant here
along with myself if it means that we do
not have to live
under your oppression i will destroy it
all and it's a crazy
crazy display of power because in that
instance they do the only thing they can
do
which is to give up right they're just
like okay fine like in that case
we surrender man like they just they
basically back up now of course they end
up fighting charles xavier he of course
survived but as you would expect had
lost the use of his legs so that kind of
brings him
closer in line with the main marvel
universe charles xavier albeit this
being in the house of imreality but we
pick up one week later
and one week later here on the island of
genocia you have magneto basically
speaking to all these liberated mutants
out there and saying like there have
been a lot of sacrifices a lot of things
that we've lost
you know but this war is one that's
going to continue to take from us right
it's going to continue to be a struggle
but as long as we keep on fighting
we will win because all they have are
machines technology
they don't have a whole lot going for
them and there's not a whole lot they
can do to stop us given all the vast
array of powers they have right
stick with me and we will win this thing
the other thing that you end up having
here is that because you had mutants who
in effect
conquered the island of genocia this
leads governments to moving further and
further towards the direction
of just waging war entirely against the
mutant population
it's one thing when you have like the
united states kind of doing it and
and no one formally declaring war and
it's another one it's kind of an
unwritten war right and it's really an
it's been an unwritten war up to this
point right it's magneto kind of
launching the strike against humanity in
response to a lot of things that
humanity's done and there will come a
point when he basically
ends up you know kind of kicking over
the last or really pulling the last
straw which sets everything in motion
but what he ends up doing is after
talking with charles xavier uh it's one
of these things where
because of the fact that he is now
running jenosha and jenosha
is effectively a nation unto itself
albeit
not necessarily recognized at the moment
with magneto being the new leader of it
xavier's response is you're you're a
governmental leader it's time to start
acting like one so if you're going to be
a head of state then it's time for us to
start meeting with other heads of state
and so what magneto does is travel
around
all these different super powered
kingdoms that exist out there the first
one he does is he goes to the inhumans
right and he basically says
once they come after us if they destroy
us they're gonna come for you and the
response to the humans initially
is we're not going to get involved right
now keep in mind black bolts the one
running the inhuman
in human kingdom right this guy's voice
is powerful enough to level entire
cities with a whisper right
it's more than enough to to obliterate
you know an entire planet at this point
here in the house of m universe magneto
was far more powerful than he was
in the main marvel universe and so while
the inhumans do not necessarily say
yes we're gonna gather our armies like
right now and rally to your cause what
they do say
is if there is an attack on jenosha then
we will meet you there as allies right
we will come to your side
should that happen something similar
happens when they go to atlantis and
they meet with neymar the submariner
namor doesn't necessarily say we're
going to fight on your cause we're not
going to bring a whole bunch of our
atlanteans you know as an army to your
to your people but what he does say is
we'll provide you with advanced arms and
armament where we'll prevent you and
provide you with advanced weapons now
the true benefit here comes in wakanda
when you have uh magneto and charles
xavier
traveling to meet with black panthers
and the cool thing that happens here is
that while black panther says
we're not going to send people to fight
alongside you well that's that's not
going to happen
we can offer you vibranium right which
is a substance unique to our country
whose vibrations can destroy metal
magneto's kind of like i don't really
need that i don't need a
metal that can destroy metal because i
can already do that myself now the
benefit of having that though
is that he can give it to other people
besides himself right so they can
basically destroy sentinels in a much
easier way on their own
well and so while magneto does accept it
he accepts it somewhat grudgingly
because what he wants is basically
t'challa to ally himself with magneto
what t'challa offers
is something better he basically signs
or is willing to sign a non-aggression
treaty with genocide
that would officially recognize it as a
sovereign nation this is huge because of
any government were to launch an attack
against genocide what they would now be
doing is launching an attack against a
sovereign nation it would mean
any response that jenosha offers is
warranted so say for example the
president of the united states were to
order a nuclear
strike on genocide then if that nuclear
strike was prevented the world of course
would know that it happened
and magneto's retaliatory strike against
the federal government and the united
states would be justified
because the u.s basically declared war
by attacking a sovereign nation this is
a huge thing it provides them some
measure of protection now
how much protection that gives them
against an enemy that doesn't really
care whether they live or die
well it's not really a whole lot going
there but it is it is important in its
way
the next thing that happens after this
is that because they are currently
occupants on genocide then the response
to the federal government you know led
really with bolivar trask being vice
president at this point
then we have to basically launch a black
ops strike right we have to launch a
strike as the most
clandestine one we can think of to
essentially take out the royal take out
the head family right take out magneto
his kids
that kind of stuff if you cut off the
head then the rest of the body dies
right the mutant population will be
scattered they'll be leaderless and
they'll be divided and they'll be easily
conquered and so leading this or really
in this
this group is what you have in bucky
barnes you have
frank simpson also known as nuke and
then you've got mimik now kind of a
quick run over
you guys don't need an explanation about
bucky barnes you guys know who that is
one of the important things to know
though is that in this house of m
continuity steve rogers never became
captain america like he never received
well i guess he did receive the super
soldier serum but he basically ended up
growing old right he never became the
captain america that you know him being
instead he's just an old war veteran
that's all he is just an aging war
veteran you see him like once in house
of m
and that's basically it frank simpson of
course is pretty much the same
except in the house of him continuity
he's intelligent uh but he basically has
his red white and blue pills of course
bringing him to various levels of
intensity and then you have mimic who
has the ability to copy the powers
of anybody he sees and he can copy more
than one power at the same time right so
he's
exceedingly powerful now under the
direction of bucky barnes and frank
simpson
and uh and mimic of course once they get
to the island mimik ends up copying the
power of everybody who's there bucky
barnes goes on his underground mission
and then you have frank simpson who goes
on his mission as well
bucky barnes intention is to basically
blow the place up right to blow the
joint to essentially destroy
everything that that you know the home
of magneto the whole nine yards to bring
it all down for frank simpson
his task is to kill the various members
of the royal family and then of course
mimic's responsibility is to kill as
many mutants as he possibly can the
issue with
bucky barnes is that once he gets to his
location and he starts planting bombs
the charles xavier
intervenes and charles xavier knows who
bucky barnes is even if he can't read
his mind because bucky barnes basically
has a device that keeps that from
happening but charles xavier's whole
thing here is when i was younger i
wanted to be like you man like i wanted
to be
like bucky barnes the sidekick of
captain america right one of the great
superheroes or really non-powered
superheroes of our time but bucky barnes
doesn't really care in his mind he's an
agent of the government and he sees
xavier magneto all the mutants that are
out there as enemies of the state
and treats them as such the result is
that he basically ends up killing
charles xavier right just stabs charles
xavier kills him on the spot
for everything else going on uh you have
mimic facing off against
off against magneto and mimik able to
duplicate his powers while he's not able
to use his powers to the same degree
that magneto can
he does have the powers of everybody
else and at the end of the day it
doesn't much
matter in the face of what magneto can
do because ultimately he ends up getting
the upper hand
on mimic when he basically summons one
of those in one of those collars that
are designed to shut down powers and has
it wrapped around the neck of mimic
shuts his powers down and then once he
crashes to the ground
beats him to death with a stick the
other thing that goes on and this is
what's so cool about this
is that frank simpson going through and
basically trying to track down the
various members of the
of magneto's family right so quicksilver
lorna wanda
and even magneto himself where he starts
trying to track them down the first
person he comes across
is is wanda right it's the scarlet witch
wanda maximoff and
at this point tries to pull the trigger
and tries to kill her and at that moment
wanda wakes right up and she's just like
you ungrateful wretch right like i i
altered reality in such a way to give
everybody everything they ever desired
and the one thing that you desired was
to be intelligent to be an intelligent
person who could operate in a higher
level capacity than just a guy who
wanted to kill stuff
but your nature cannot be changed so you
have no place in this world and she
literally
wipes him from existence right he just
ceases to exist and that's the end of
frank simpson so
this is one of those instances when
wanda is well aware of what she's doing
in the house of imreality she totally
understands the power she has she knows
that she's changed everything and
everybody's just kind of playing apart
and you see that happen periodically
over the course of house of m where she
just uses her powers and a person just
ceases to exist
because by all standards of measurement
here in the house of m universe wand is
god
no one can stop her nobody can stop her
we also know the effects of house of m
reached all the way into the multiverse
and so while she only
only really is modifying a singular
universe or at least that seemed to be
the case
during the main half of him event she's
still incredibly powerful
right just universally powerful but in
in the aftermath of charles xavier dying
uh two things happen the first is that
bucky tries to make his move
against against magneto and of course
shooting him with what are effectively
ceramic bullets and also wielding a
ceramic knife magneto summons the shield
of captain america uses it to cut off
buckybarn's head and he's out of the
picture but with charles xavier being
dead
now they have a martyr now they have
somebody they can rally rally around
and so this leads to magneto basically
taking the fight directly to humanity
right with saying
that the attempts of bucky barnes and
those guys to take out magneto and his
family and all the various mutants who
were there on uh on genocide
was effectively a strike by a by a a
sovereign nation
against another sovereign nation right
so the united states declared war on
genocide this means genocide returns
and kind by declaring war on the united
states and does it in probably the most
epic way ever when you've got bolivar
trash
basically talking to the president of
the united states then suddenly captain
america shield comes flying in through
the window the secret service comes
racing in like we got to get you out of
here as fast as we can
and it's like like they're like we're
under attack right the enemy's out there
and they're like
who like who's possibly here and they're
like the worst case scenario that
magneto has shown up here to the white
house
along with his whole host of of mutant
of like his mutant army and it's just
like
take the fight to him some of us might
die that's fine but the war ends here
and now either we die or we take out the
federal government right we wipe the
whole thing out
and we're the ones that take that that
take control of all of it and so what
you have there is that aboard air force
two because the president
is currently in a bunker and because of
the fact that uh that the vice president
is the one that's essentially running
the show here the vice president's
response is
i'm taking command of everything right
like i'm i'm basically the one running
the show
get me norad and starts firing nukes off
it off at jenosha
right now in response to that with all
these nukes basically just flying across
the across the whole place
magneto accounted for this right magneto
expected that to happen
and so where all these missiles are
flying towards genocide enter
black bolt and news against quasi-sonic
scream destroys all the nuclear missiles
before they can detonate
at the same time it allowed forge who's
a mutant that basically his mutant power
allows him to be like tony stark where
he's super intelligent had created a
device that allowed magneto and all
those guys to focus in to hone in on
where the signal was coming from
that was controlling all the sentinels
only for them to find out that it's
coming from a shield helicarrier they
trace it to its location
and using gateway who's a mutant that
has the ability to create portals or
create uh teleportation portals
basically teleports them aboard the
helicarrier and as soon as they get in
there like magneto's like done right
like quicksilver races through all the
guns are basically
are taken away from all these soldiers
they have nothing that they can do to
magneto he crashes the entire
helicarrier down into the water
and then in turn bolivar trash activates
the sentinels to come pouring in on
magneto since they have them in one
location
and because these are not uh metal-based
sentinels magneto cannot
cannot directly control them now the
sentinels when they arrive basically
their programming takes over and they
say like those humans in the target area
non-lethal measures only follow our
trask says no
right like override and says kill every
kill every mutant in here collateral
damage is perfectly fine their override
goes through and the sentinels just
start attacking everything they see
this gives magneto a perfect opportunity
where he puts bolivar trask into one of
his force fields
sends it up to a sentinel and because
the sentinel simply just registers a
mutant power
even though bolivar trask is not the one
doing it it totally incinerates
all of our trash in an effort to get to
magneto now ultimately of course
bolivar trash being completely destroyed
uh he's you know really there's the
sentinel's just kind of running
according to their programming
and then from there it all falls apart
pretty fast right like magneto and his
guys they all just start tearing through
all of these uh all these sentinels
right just crushing them with like dump
trucks and all kinds of materials
different things like that
carol danvers actually uh who you guys
know is as
captain marvel carol danvers is a person
who does have powers but she doesn't
agree with what the federal government
and shield have been doing
so she actually turn coats and joins the
side of magneto and helps him fight off
all these various sentinel threats which
is a very powerful ally to have at his
side but again like the battle turns
very very fast until they basically end
up locating where the president's at
right they basically locate air force
one which was essentially kept off the
grid of course air force one is not
really a plane that readily broadcasts
its signal so anybody can know where
it's at right because in that case what
stops some crazy group from attacking it
which is exactly what magneto did right
like magneto literally figures out its
location
after searching the entire world for
this particular signature
and once he locates it brings the plane
crashing down right brings it into one
of the sentinels crashes in the
sentinel's head which decapitates it
that frees magneto and then he brings
the brings air force one down to the
ground and
drags the president out and says okay we
have one here
this is it right like the news and
everybody's here and magneto is like
this war is over we've
we've captured the president of the
united states we're all done following
that what he ends up doing is they end
up basically breaking into the records
of the united states government through
like the pentagon
all that kind of stuff and they they're
able to essentially confirm that there
was a multinational anti-mutant
conspiracy that was being spearheaded by
multiple governments right and this was
all basically thrown to the people
magneto in his current position as ruler
of the united states
expands his influence out and then
effectively conquers the world now
for the most part all the various people
who are out there all the various
governments
are allowed some measure of autonomy
where they're able to do their own thing
but at the end of the day
they all answer directly to magneto
right they all answer directly to him
and so in the aftermath of all this
mutants just start coming out right just
ch guns blaze them like they're they're
just coming out
everywhere just coming out swinging
they're they're officially allowed to
make themselves public and and humans
effectively become second-class citizens
that mutants now become the top-tier
class
in society and so as the story
essentially closes out you have magneto
who's a little bit sad over everything
that's happening but wanda starts to
comfort him and she says like isn't this
what you spent your entire life fighting
for
and the response of magneto is yes it's
everything that i've ever wanted all of
my dreams
have effectively come true and that was
the purpose of the house of m the
purpose of house of m
was to give everybody everything they
ever wanted and while the conflict was
bloody and while a lot of mutants
a lot of mutant lives were lost in the
end magneto won
the mutant population no longer has to
live in fear they no longer have to live
have to worry about being killed
or assassinated or anything along those
lines they can finally live
in peace and take their proper place in
society as magneto sees it so with that
being said guys uh this is just one of
the stories that came in the aftermath
of house of him let me know if you guys
want me to color others cover other
stuff right because when we did the
original house of end story we didn't
really cover
a lot of the tie-in storylines we just
did like the main story itself
and called it a day so if any of you
guys want to see any of the other stuff
because there's a lot of other stuff
right there's like house of m spider-man
there's house of m what is it psylocke
and and like what is it the phoenix i
think it is uh there's all kinds of
crazy stuff with with house of van
let me know what you guys want to see uh
and if you guys are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
so
[Music]
you